il est libre depuis juin empreint de la
coupe de france de football
longwy ne veut pas se laisser oublier
l'autre problème d'israël l'appelation
70 % de hausse en main non mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir les feux de forêt ont
repris avec violence dans le midi ce
matin on avait espéré un court moment
que la situation serait devenue
pratiquement normale en provence en fait
il n'y a pas de répit le feu a ressurgi
par une trentaine de nouveaux foyers
hier déjà les incendies de forêt dans la
région de boulouris avait causé le
retard de nombreux trains sur la ligne
paris nice
les rames avaient dû attendre plusieurs
heures en gare de nice et de
saint-raphaël afin de pouvoir repartir
tant le danger était sérieux c'est le
vent qui on tourne on a évité le pire
hier près de saint-raphaël ou avec une
rapidité foudroyante 500 hectares de
forêt ont été des il n'y a pas eu de
victimes mais le feu poussé par un
mistral soufflant à 80 km/heure a
directement menacé trois terrains de
camping et des piles à dont les
occupants
être évacués celle incendie le plus
important qu'ils se soient déclarés dans
la région depuis 1962 aujourd'hui la
situation est devenue vraiment
dramatique sans qu'il y ait pour
l'instant de victimes mais n'a pas pu en
provence depuis trois mois et attisé par
un vent violent près de 30 incendies ont
éclaté dans les départements des
bouches-du-rhône du var et alpes
maritimes et de l'accord les exemples
c'est 100 hectares brûlaient encore à
15km de manosque plus de 1000 hectares
près de brignoles et le massif des
maures et menacé mille hectares déjà
brûlé près de caen joue à nice à
marseille de salon de provence à la
corse
tous les moyens en hommes et matériels
sont mobilisés 17 cents pompiers
travaillent sans relâche dans le var
soutenu par l'armée
les 12 canadair de la protection civile
et un décès 6 aménager des versants à
lui seul 12 mille litres d'eau à chaque
passage sont en action sur les
différents foyers
la météo pour demain est pessimiste le
vent ne devrait pas faiblir
les réserves d'eau dans le var s'épuise
elles sont au niveau qu'elles
s'éteignent généralement fin août les
pompiers partent plus pressé depuis le
1er juin ils sont intervenus parce que
chaque jour
trente mille hectares ont disparu en
fumée depuis le premier joueur 12000
pour le seul département des bouches du
rhône le ministre l'agriculture pierre
méhaignerie a promis 20 % de crédits
supplémentaires pour la forêt l'année
prochaine et de nouvelles mesures de
protection et d'intervention
mais pour l'instant par malveillance
coup par imprudence l'écologie et
l'économie de la provence et de la corse
sont gravement menacés car cette forêt
mais de 20 à 50 ans pour se reconstituer
l'etna dans l'éruption avait été si
spectaculaire au début de la semaine
s'est peu à peu et assécher l'écoulement
de la lave par est stoppée mais là aussi
dépendantes il ferait ans disparue sous
une mer de cendres de même que des
plantations d'oliviers de vigne et des
verges
la plus grande marée noire de l'histoire
celle qui provient du puits sous-marin
de pétrole qui a crevé dans le golfe du
mexique continue à s'avancer vers les
côtes au mexique même les experts
prétendent que la pollution et moins
toxique qu'on ne le craignait mais cela
ne rassure nullement des populations
côtières qui sont très effrayée par les
formidables de pétrone qui viennent
lécher les plages notre part notre pain
quotidien vote aujourd'hui 22 % de plus
qu'il y a un an depuis que le prix en a
été libéré libéré cela veut dire que le
prix n'est plus fixé par arrêté
ministériel
ce qui était le cas précédemment en
somme les boulangers peuvent vendre leur
pain le prix qu'ils veulent lorsque l'an
passé le prix donc a été libéré on
pensait qu'il y aurait un garde-fou la
concurrence or celle ci ne semble pas
avoir joué
bref le pain augmente partout avant de
suivre le reportage de philippe gassot
sachez que selon les statistiques le
français consomme chaque jour en moyenne
180 grammes de pain en ma main chaque
français en mangent donc 70 qui descend
le sandwich est avant tout le pain
support des rillettes et du jambon
beurre pour les étrangers le français
porte un béret une moustache et une
baguette sous le bras pour terminer le
tableau pourrait même ajouter qu'il
n'est pas content
quoique opus d'un ami le prix un livre
comme un gruyère
mais le club du cheikh
pour le syndicat fo la libération des
prix et des services était une erreur
pour l'union fédérale des consommateurs
la libération du prix du pain est
l'exemple qu'il ne fallait pas faire
les professionnels pensent que le pain
comme les autres produits doit suivre le
coût de la vie monsieur on libéralise le
prix du pain mais on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
quand même une augmentation qui dépasse
les 20%
ah oui mais enfin match pour voir ce que
ça fait 15 ans que je suis ici quand je
suis arrivé il ya quinze ans avec le
prix d'une baguette de pain j'achetais
grands journaux 3 tab 10 1 litre de lait
maintenant est ce qu'au prix d'une
baguette de pain je peux plus acheter
mon journal
le litre de lait
et adam g tous les fantasmes à votre
avis qui responsable de cette
augmentation du prix du plein qu'est-ce
que vous avez fini
l'augmentation a suivi le cours de la
vie et je crois que si elles auraient
suivi le cours des autres produits à la
baguette de pain serait beaucoup plus
cher saumon dit vous seriez sensible à
une nouvelle hausse
on va savoir comment là on a reçu la
nouvelle facture de farine et de riz une
nouvelle augmentation du prix du pain
aux nouveaux amis
en échange de la liberté des prix les
boulangers devait faire l'effort
d'embauché dix mille personnes dans
l'année or c'est loin d'être le cas
3000 ouvriers boulangers sont à la
recherche d'un emploi soit une
augmentation du chômage dans la
profession de 31% par rapport à l'année
dernière
alors on n'embauche pas si on veut
envoyer du monde du personnel ont cours
actuellement
croyez-moi je rentre de vacances j'ai
passé une annonce sur france soir
des gens sont venus présenter et seront
sans aucune qualification la liberté des
prix dans la boulangerie doit servir de
test pour de nouvelles mesures
gouvernementales dans ce commerce de
détail comment va être jugé ce premier
test d'un jeu comme président de la
confédération française de la
boulangerie invités d'antenne de midi
aujourd'hui les boulangers ne doivent
pas être des boucs émissaires
le pain en valeur absolue répètes il
n'est pas cher comparé au privé journaux
et des timbres enfin il s'est félicité
d'avoir juguler ce mois ci une eau
supplémentaire sommes en train de faire
un effort à porter pour éviter une
augmentation du prix du pain
car le prix du blé vient d'être augmenté
au 1er ou et ça c'est une décision
européenne
les meuniers serait en droit de nous
augmenter la farine dès le premier où
nous leur avons demandé d'attendre le
plus possible nous avons demandé aux
boulangers date ans justement monsieur
conclure que cette augmentation
n'intervienne le plus tard possible dans
la nuit heure justement dernière
question est ce que vous croyez qu'une
augmentation du pain peut intervenir
mais bien sûr que je le crois étant
donné que nous avons nous avons deux
augmentations importantes sur nos
charges
ce sont d'abord les salaires qui
représente 40% du prix du pain ce sont
la farine que représente 35% du prix du
pain les salaires par convention
collective doivent augmenter au 1er
octobre et la farine gâteau mort
l'essayer de jeu viral boulanger alors
où l'ange et aux moyens maintenant je ne
peux dire non la difficulté si monsieur
nous remote permet d'envoyer une
circulaire à tous mais boulanger pour
leur indiquer le niveau d'une
augmentation on en revient à taza seul
en mer quand le dollar était revenu lors
à la fièvre depuis hier le métal jaune
un registre de nouveaux records à
londres comme aux états unis qui sont
les grands marchés occidentaux de l'or
ici à côté plus de 300 dollars l'once
une nouvelle fois et à paris tous les
regards se sont portés sur le pognon qui
a atteint pour la première fois dans son
histoire le prix de 400 francs et puis
aujourd'hui si vous vouliez acheter un
kilo d'or c'est à dire un lingot à la
bourse de paris
il fallait sortir de votre portefeuille
près de quarante quatre mille francs
c'est la faiblesse du dollar
causée notamment par l'accélération de
l'inflation aux états unis qui explique
en grande partie cette montée des cours
de long la coupe de france en argent qui
avait été gagné par les footballeurs de
nantes il y a deux mois au parc des
princes avait disparu hier des locaux du
club
elle avait été visée emprunté par des
ouvriers sidérurgistes syndicalistes de
la cfdt de longwy après avoir hésité
quelques heures car d'abord il voulait
un match de football
nantes strasbourg sur le terrain de
longwy même les emprunteurs ont décidé
de rendre l'objet d'art au football club
de nantes sans demander de contrepartie
les syndicalistes ont déclaré qu'ils
avaient dans cette opération
spectaculaire afin d'attirer l'attention
sur la situation du bassin sidérurgique
de longwy longwy est une des villes les
plus touchées par la crise qui secoue la
sidérurgie française européenne
les licenciements annoncés par usine à
et par la chaire ce seront vous le savez
compensées par la création d'emplois
notamment dans l'industrie automobile le
personnel licencié bénéficient d'un
certain nombre d' aide financière fait
d'une prime de 50 mille francs accordés
à ceux qui sont obligés d'abandonner
leur emploi mais comment vit-on à longwy
comment s'effectue cette mutation
industrielle comment les hommes
réagissent t-il à ce bouleversement que
connaît leur vie professionnelle
au delà donc des chiffres et des
démonstrations économique
c'est le destin de milliers d'hommes qui
est concerné et ce sont ces hommes là
qu'a rencontré jean-claude remous
le lion d'or à longlaville le patron
s'appelle pierre boucher 27 ans ancien
sidérurgiste
il a quitté volontairement lusine il y à
un mois avec une prime de 50 mille
francs et des indemnités de licenciement
1300 salariés ont fait comme lui à
longwy des jeunes le plus souvent des
militants parfois désormais perdu pour
les syndicats une surprise aussi pour
les patrons le succès de la prime des
six mais certains services
qui doivent embaucher des intérims en
tout cas la plupart des volontaires ne
regrette rien on est bien au travail
pour mon travail et famille c'était bien
la vie familiale vous changé pour vous à
hollywood
alex va pas vous voyez pas être
travaillés bon moi je travaille et je
faisais une journée pour les dimanches
on est passés france en les jours fériés
c'était pareil tu as beaucoup de trucs
s'accordaient pas encore huit mois
non ça va
autre mesure prévue par la convention
sociale signée le 24 juillet par tous
les syndicats sauf la cgt
les mutations 700 salariés mutés à la
chiers de longwy dont 663 travailleront
sur place à usine
pourtant les mutations sont mal acceptée
depuis que la direction a annoncé que
seuls 129 employés techniciens et agents
de maîtrise en surnombre pourront partir
à 50 ans avec 80% de leur salaire
on va on est muté à 9 milliards us
hinault qu'est ce que vous allez faire
là on n'en sait rien mais vous êtes
considéré comme un travailleur et qu'un
poste pénible vous oui oui à ces risques
vous avez passé 50 ans oui 52
conseillers partir en pré-retraite oui
on a mis les états membres prêts
mais c'est à dire qui c'est à dire les
corneilles
et les ouvriers
et il travaille
vous savez pas exactement ce que vous
allez faire usine en rien du tout rien
du tout certains week-ends voire avant
mais moi qui ferai moi de 50 ans entend
les voir avant il avait droit à trois
essais mais nous rien on commence le 27
quelques jours la halle usine ici puis
l'invité
vous allez garder le même salaire
d'après les trappes oui le même travail
arnon un tueur ment pas bonsoir à tous
vous allez syndicats savaient que les
mutations ferait des mécontents et les
mesures sociales ont été mus et la
combativité lui de la radio libre cdt
ici n'aimait plus qu'une fois par
semaine ition celle de la cgt à la télé
lorraine coeur d'acier a plié son
antenne pour le mois d'août un carré
d'irréductibles poursuit les opérations
coup de poing comme l'enlèvement de la
coupe de france de football
en multipliant les conférences de presse
il explique que celle anesthésie par
l'argent à coup de primes qui permet aux
patrons d'opérer des coupes sombres mais
demande-t-il
donc l etat va se réveiller le bassin de
longwy on a déjà plus de cinq mille
retraités d'un bassin de l'envié on va
rajouter quatre mille avec la nouvelle
convention ça à faire 9000 on rajoute
quatre mille chômeurs dont la plupart
sont jeunes s'affairent
quinze mille 15 mille personnes dont
plus de la moitié sont encore en état de
travailler
qu'est ce que ça va être le bassin de
vie demain le fait en soi même des
informations sociales en elle-même
ce n'est pas mauvais mais ce qui est
mauvais c'est le bassin de la vie qu'est
ce qu'il va devenir
il faut que le gouvernement et les
patrons ils sachent et le bassin de vie
ne veut pas mourir
ça c'est le problème c'est le problème
des emplois c'est le problème des
chômeurs c'est le problème de la vie qui
doit continuer à vivre parce qu est une
ville de retraités ce n'est pas une
ville pleine de vie vendée via aucune à
venir pour le moment la restructuration
est en cours
à la chiers avec les départs volontaires
les mutations il y a aussi les
pré-retraites 200 cette année à 50 ou 55
ans 12 ans depuis le mois de février à
la chair of oral écrit j'ai été replacé
à la série le mans
vous avez quel âge je vais sur 56 11
janvier vous avez fait votre dans votre
travail ce matin ce matin j'ai fait
terminée lui qu'est ce que vous allez
ferme pendant votre droite
ben je m'occupe du cimetière et puis
c'est le jardin
longwy le rebelle s'est assoupi pendant
l'été déjà des syndicalistes qui ont
empoché la prime de 50 mille francs
chercher du travail ailleurs
cette année 1500 emplois sont supprimés
à longwy
l'an prochain ce sera trois mille huit
cents à faire de radio riposte suite
monsieur gaston defferre président du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale et maire de marseille demande
dans un télégramme au premier ministre
l'ouverture d'un débat à l'assemblée
nationale suivie d'un vote sur les
problèmes de l'information de la rentrée
dans ce télégramme adressé à monsieur
raymond barre que ceux de fer estime je
cite que le monopole technique ne doit
pas être confondu avec le monopole
politique exercée par les instances
gouvernementales et contre lequel le
parti socialiste s'élève fin de citation
la page étrangères en espagne était un
militaire revendique l'attentât commis
avant-hier contre une patrouille de la
garde civile
et elle rappelle je cite encore qu'elle
n'est pas disposé à baisser la tête
devant le joueur presseur du
gouvernement de madrid
elle répète qu'elle poursuivrait la
lutte armée tant qu'elle n'aura pas
obtenu que toutes ces revendications
soient satisfaites
le 14 août 1960 ma fille est presque dix
ans les troupes britanniques en traitant
le mystère c'est à dire en irlande du
nord pour essayer de maintenir l'ordre
mais pendant de longues années les
incidents sanglants dont se saisit
produire que vous avez suivi sur vos
écrans puis il ya eu une accalmie mais
aujourd'hui à la proche de la date du
10e anniversaire
le climat est à nouveau tendue et la
violence par erreur des incidents qui
ont fait jusqu'à présent six blessés
civils à belfast où les barricades ont
refait leur a paru
du reste les manifestations les jours
prochains
ce qui a mobilisé la police de l'isère a
supprimé toutes les permissions déjà
plusieurs quartiers de belfast de l'ong
berry sont interdits à la circulation
alors que la police savait
à toutes les familles de continuer à la
maison leurs enfants adolescents le 14
août prochain le jour du 10e
anniversaire de l'intervention
britannique en irlande du nord
peut-être l'amorcé d'une détente dans la
crise aérienne le premier ministre
mauritanien le lieutenant-colonel et
dallas est arrivé aujourd'hui à rabat
pour s'entretenir avec le roi hassan 2
objectifs de ce voyage exposé au maroc
allait raison de l'accord que la
mauritanie vient de signer avec le
polisario en fait le lieutenant-colonel
aïda la vache surtout essayer de
rassurer hassan ii qui vient de
rapatrier son contingent stationnés en
mauritanie
et puis des images qui semblent sortir
d'un autre âge il s'agit là d'une des
manifestations classiques pourrions-nous
dire du ku klux klan en alabama
toute la panoplie du grand jeu théâtral
est là mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper
l'été dernier déjà le clan avait
provoqué des émeutes dans certaines
villes du sud ses membres n'hésitent
plus à descendre dans la rue pour clamer
la supériorité de la race blanche
leur influence ne cesse de croître
décidément les vieux mythes ne sont pas
morts
israël vit actuellement dans un climat
d'incertitudes même si le danger d'une
guerre sont des carpes et incertitudes
pour la santé du premier ministre
menahem begin incertitudes sur la suite
de la carrière de manche et d'iam
atteint d'un cancer et qui publie
aujourd'hui dans la presse israélienne
un article sur cette terrible maladie
laquelle dit-il ne l'effrayé pas car il
a trop souvent déjà vu la mort 1
servitude
j'y reviens à propos des négociations
avec l'egypte
incertitude surtout en ce qui concerne
l'orientation de la politique américaine
à l'égard de l'état hébreu
bien que le président carter et déclaré
hier qu'il était opposé à la création
d'un état palestinien indépendant et que
la plupart des chefs d'état arabes qui
l'avait vu récemment l'était dit il
aussi
en fait l'aide financière américaine
représente en quelque sorte le poumon 10
fed
d'autant plus que l'économie du pays
connaît des difficultés de plus en plus
grande
marqué par une inflation record à tel
point que les ménagères israéliennes se
sont rués depuis 24 heures sur les
produits alimentaires car elles
craignent qu'une hausse des prix
annoncée ne soit 2 50%
dominique fleury qui rentrent d'israël
vous présente son enquête
à l'heure où des dizaines de milliers de
touristes envahissent l'état d'israël la
population elles manifestent une
certaine inquiétude inquiétude devant la
dégradation de plus en plus grande de la
situation et qu'elle ait une situation
marquée notamment par une inflation
record qui atteint aujourd'hui près de
70 % et la hausse du coût de la vie qui
dépasse les 4% par mois il est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de mécanismes sont
mis en place par le gouvernement pour
protéger la population
ainsi les salaires et les punks sont
indexés et à court terme les
particuliers ne semble pas trop touchés
par l'inflation reste que la hausse des
prix accroît les inégalités en frappant
en premier lieu les plus défavorisés bon
c'est un pays de guer deuxièmement se
laver très cher moi par exemple je
travaille dans une usine textile 11 min
pour moi ça me suffit je peux vivre j'ai
une femme et deux enfants
d'ailleurs moi je gagne 7 salaires parce
que je travaille les dix neuf 19 années
dans cette usine est un ouvrier
travaille 6 7 ans et peut pas dire très
difficile et vous dépensez à peu près
combien pour l'alimentation pour rien
pour la nourriture moins que 70% à part
ça il faut payer les dettes
vous payez la maison on habite il fait
tout ce qui a entouré cette visite est
très difficile on peut pas sans danger
on peut pas on veut économiser
fin juillet l'essence augmenté de 40%
les transports publics de 25% le café de
28%
les matériaux de construction de 10 %
une balance commerciale en déséquilibre
ajoutons enfin qu israël est le pays le
plus endetté du monde plus de 75
milliards de francs de dettes dont la
moitié aux états unis
il faut comprendre quelles sont les
causes de l'inflation et ferait une
première cause c'est l'énormité du
fardeau à se voir un petit pays 3
millions de trois millions et demi
d'habitants alors faire face à des
dépenses énormes de défense à des
dépenses lourdes de développement
économique et social à la construction
du pays à l'intégration des immigrants
face à toutes ses dépenses lui a pas
tellement de possibilités de faire un
ordre de priorité qui permettrait de
couper très durement un ou un autre type
de dépenses de ses obligés de faire tout
à la fois nous avait là un facteur
inflationniste par excellence la
deuxième raison qui est également une
raison objective et que nous sommes
terriblement dépendant en matière de
ressources naturelles ou de ressources
énergétiques de l'étranger ce qui fait
que chaque variation de prix de près
internationale en matière de pétrole par
exemple se répercute automatiquement
deux plein fouet sur ce qui se passe
chez nous et la troisième raison elle
les raisons profondes structurelles de
cette inflation est une raison de type
un peu différente
elle tient à la une décision délibérée
voulu de ne pas pratiquer le chômage à
savoir à la différence des pays
occidentaux qui utilisent le chômage
comme instrument de lutte contre
l'inflation
c'est un phénomène connu en israël
la décision a été prise au plan
politique par le gouvernement précédent
comme par par le gouvernement actuel de
ne pas recourir au chômage comme moyen
de lutte contre l'inflation sur le long
terme c'est vrai l'inflation tend à
briser l'homogénéité sociale en israël
qui caractérisait jusqu'à un certain
temps à la structure de sociétés
israéliennes et de soins de ville elle
est particulièrement dangereuse
ce danger préoccupe actuellement les
stades routes le syndicat des
travailleurs israéliens un plan vient
d'être proposé au gouvernement l'an qui
prévoit entre autres une augmentation de
l'impôt sur le capital
d'autre part les syndicats estiment
contrairement au gouvernement que
l'indexation des salaires ne rattrape
pas entièrement la place qu'est-ce que
vous douce etc l'indexé serre n'est pas
de sens qu'on sent les l'index du coût
de la vie chère et p&o salaires et un
lien seulement à 70% du coût de la vie
tant que les salariés pétrole perd 30
pour ça cela je pense ou suffit pour
vous démontrer combien que le salarié
est touché et ses salariés paient chaque
fin de mois leurs impôts par contre dans
les hommes d'affaires et des privés est
ce la paix et seulement vers la fin de
l'année offert comme dans une situation
où la déflation va arriver et ce cas
presque 100% donc point ils ne font que
gagner de cette situation par contre
cela n engage pas à chaque fin du mois
il doit payer ses impôts
reste qu'à la différence des pays
européens on considère ici dans les
milieux économiques que l'inflation même
galopante n'est pas un phénomène aussi
grave que le pensent des économistes
classiques sans pour autant sous-estimer
la nécessité de lutter contre
l'inflation il faut transformer
profondément les structures de la
société israélienne
la vente plus productives et moins
fondées sur le secteur tertiaire et sur
le commerce ou l'administration
et vous pensez que tout cela peut
réduire les inégalités en même temps
cela réduit une bonne croissance
économique une vraie croissance
économique saine est fondée sur le
développement industriel réduira les
inégalités sociales mais en israël à
chaque fois qu'un problème prend une
certaine dimension on y ajoute une
pointe d'humour
pendant des siècles a déclaré un
israélien nous avions la réputation
d'être des financiers exceptionnels la
crise économique montre que dans ce
domaine également nous le sommes guère
différent nous avons nous aussi
de médiocres économistes c'est la fin
d'une certaine beetle
situation économique d'autant plus
difficile que contrairement à une
certaine légende très répandue l'aide de
la diaspora c'est à dire marsan ou des
israélites dispersés dans le monde ne
représente que deux et demi pour cent du
budget nation
l'inde a lancé aujourd'hui sa première
fusée porteuse de satellites fabriqués
entièrement chez elle mais la ferme a
pas réussi complètement l'un des
éléments de la fusée s'est abîmé en mer
celui là même qui contenait des
instruments de contrôle mais le
satellites meteosat lancé par l'europe
et qui tourne fort bien nous envoie des
images de la terre telle qu'elle vivait
aujourd'hui avec les explications de
laurent broomhead nous allons donc
savoir le temps qu'il va faire demain et
après demain
en un week end où il y aura beaucoup de
monde sur les routes et où les choses se
présentent mieux comme voici l'europe
aujourd'hui de 9 heures à 14 heures le
tourbillon de nuages en jaune clair sur
les images tourbillon qui nous a apporté
la tempe et hier se déplace vers l'est
mais déjà d'autres nuages ont recouvert
cet après-midi l'ouest du pays
après leur passage nous devrions
retrouver le soleil et le bouton ces
images transmises par l' agence spatiale
européenne été prise aujourd'hui donc au
dessus de l'europe satellite est au
dessus de l'afrique
voici maintenant la carte française pour
demain sur le sud du pays du soleil
soleil avec du mistral tout de même
encore assez fort mais il aura tendance
à légèrement faiblir sur tout le reste
du pays tout le nord est bien encore
nuageux à très nuageux même de la manche
orientale au vin et au nord-est avec
encore des pluies dans le nord-est mais
au contraire dans l'ouest le temps
s'améliorera lentement avec des
éclaircies qui deviendront plus belle
dimanche et ce temps nettement plus beau
qui enverra le pays et même s'améliorera
encore malheureusement cette
amélioration si elle sera durable sur
toute la moitié sud du pays ne durera
sans doute que deux ou trois jours sur
la moitié nord mais c'est déjà ça
quelques variations sur vénus les
japonais estiment le mariage
indispensable à l'intégration sociale et
voit d'un mauvais oeil du célibat
prolonge les dépêches
arrivé de tokyo cet après-midi vise que
les agents soient très maniable
fleurissent comme d'esprit c'est en
chine au contraire
l'amour se voit fixer des limites
étroites le quotidien du peuple blâme
cette semaine ce qui sape h avec un zèle
et
ccif aux murmures du clair de lune est
un dirigeant d'entreprise de la province
de liaoning vient de perdre sa place
parce qu'ayant eu neuf enfants
il a ainsi montré concrètement sans
opposition à la politique de la
planification des naissances en france
l'association des juristes catholiques
du languedoc rappelle aux dames et
demoiselles que s'exhiber les seins nus
sur une plage constitue toujours un
délit mais c'est une remarque qui ne
concerne pas les concurrentes du tour de
france à la voile sur des camions les 25
voiliers du tour de france ont été
transbordés sans histoire de
l'atlantique à la méditerranée à port
barcarès ils ont retrouvé leur gréement
basé voile et leurs éléments la mer avec
en prime le vent et le soleil
brest leader de la course précède
marseille d'une heure et vingt minutes
pour les méridionaux qui arrivent ici
sur leur terrain le retard est important
mais pas impossible à combler fini les
problèmes de marée et de courant seul le
vent compte désormais
ce qu'on a pu mais pas sur un parent
enfant 30
théoriquement sont adhérentes comment
il prend pas prendre de l'avant pour
mars
le problème avec le petit temps
première étape en méditerranée port
barcarès cap d'agde 60 km à parcourir la
moyenne sera soutenu plus de 7 noeuds ce
qui constitue une belle performance face
au vent pour des bateaux de cette taille
marseille gagnera cette étape précédant
deauville de 13 secondes des 25
équipages franchiront la ligne d'arrivée
pratiquement ensemble sept minutes
séparant le 1er mai dernier le tour de
france à la voile c'est une course bien
sûr mais à chaque étape c'est aussi la
promotion de la voile en particulier
pour les jeunes une vingtaine
d'optimisme
sont ainsi mis à la disposition de tous
et tabarly en herbe
quinze mille bateaux de ce type
d'arrivée actuellement en france pour
les jeunes de 7 à 15 ans c'est par
excellence le bateau d'initiation de
bars et de s'occuper un petit peu tous
tirer la corde il faut un petit peu tout
ce temps sont difficiles parce qu'on
sent pas me sentir
l'optimiste son histoire il a été créé
en 1948 aux états unis non pas dans un
cabinet d'architecturé navale mais tout
simplement dans la rue
en effet le maire d'une ville ayant
décidé d'interdire aux enfants de
dévaler les rues dans leurs caisses en
bois à 4 ou un homme eut l'idée
d'enlever les roues et d'ajouter une
voile l'optimiste est né un bateau tout
simple dont le prix varie de 3 à 6 mille
francs à 6000 francs les coques
importées de suède sont de véritables
oeuvres de marqueterie facile à
transporter par d'entretien autant de
raisons qui expliquent le succès de ce
bateau chez les enfants deux cent mille
en circulation sur le globe et aux
derniers championnats du monde à la
baule 26 nations étaient représentées
dans un instant le troisième tour du
championnat de france de football avec
un certain nombre de matchs qui devrait
s'inscrire sur vos écrans les voici
nantes monaco bastia strasbourg étaient
des rats et caetera et il y a un cerveau
nombre de matches particulièrement
intéressant et bien nous les avons mis
en tête mais surtout marseille
saint-etienne et celui des deux qui
gagnera occupera une place de choix dans
le classement vous aurez les résultats
de tous ses matches d'autres
informations au cours de deux dernières
éditions du journal télévisé que vous
présenterez claude demain vous verrez
des images du football parce qu autre
chose dans en seine 2010 co-présentera
manyan bilalian et si vous le voulez
bien nous nous retrouverons à 21 bonsoir